To explain cross-site request forgeries, I want to first go through a little example.
And for this example, to explain cross-site request forgeries, I want to first go through
a little example.
And for this example, we need someone who makes too much money.
John?
Hey, those Canadian pesos?
All right.
So let's imagine John here, who obviously makes too much money.
He just stands around counting it.
So I'd like you to imagine a scenario, okay?
So John is, you know, we're going to imagine in the morning, okay?
So he's sitting there in the morning, sipping his over-priced latte because he makes too much money, right?
And he's reading his newspaper that's been ironed for him because, you know, he's got people to do that.
So when John is going through his morning ritual, he also likes to log into his online banking system.
Hey, John, who do you bank with?
That's okay.
Never mind.
Don't need to know.
I know who it is.
So John likes to log into his online bank and check how much money he has there to sort of roll around virtually,
like Scrooge McDuck in hell with his money.
And I'm going to be the baddie here.
And I'm going to know that John is doing that.
Okay, so that's the scenario I want you to imagine, okay?
So here's what's going to happen.
I'm going to send a request to John.
I'm going to send to the URL.
And that URL, and I'm going to somehow trick him into clicking on that URL.
When he clicks on that URL, it's going to send a request to his online bank,
requesting fund transfers from his account to my account.
Now, when John clicks on that link, what's going to happen?
So if he clicks on that link to transfer funds from his account to my account,
what's his bank going to do when it receives that request?
Well, in setting up this scenario, I said very clearly that John was logged in.
And so when he clicks on that URL, what's his online bank going to do?
Well, it's going to see a valid request coming from a valid user, John,
to transfer funds from his account to my account.
So the server is going to execute that request.
And all $13 that John has in his account is going to get transferred into my account.
This is essentially what cross-state request forageories look like.
So let's walk through the technicalities of here.
So we have our baddie here.
Our baddie forages a request for fund transfers.
So he'd obviously, he or she would obviously have to do a little bit of research here
to figure out exactly what URL would need to look like to transfer the funds.
But let's assume our baddie has figured that out.
They forage this request. They create this URL.
And then our baddie here sends that URL that hyperlink to our victim here.
And through social engineering, something like that,
somehow tricks our victim into clicking on that link.
And when that user clicks on the link and sends that request to the web server,
what's the web server do?
Well, it does exactly what it's designed to do.
It's receiving a valid request from a valid user, so it executes the requests.
And some funds are transferred to, say, the baddie's bank account.
So this is the heart of cross-state request forageory.
It's that it's a valid request coming from a valid user.
And this is not actually as hard as you think it is.
Because of one very interesting little technique that we have
that we use all the time on the web nowadays.
You've probably noticed when you log into a lot of websites,
you'll see that little button that tick-pock that says,
keep me logged in for two weeks.
When you do that, what's being stored on your computer system is a cookie.
So your system, every time you go to that website,
your system will send that cookie to the web server.
And the web server will, that cookie contains a unique identifier.
And so the server knows, aha, that's you.
And so you don't actually necessarily have to have the user logged in
right at that exact moment when the baddie here sends this request.
It can often be hours, days later, after someone has logged in.
But because of these persistent connections,
these keep me logged in for two weeks.
These types of attacks can often be performed much, much later.
Or the baddie here could first do a cross-site scripting attack
to obtain the user's cookie.
Lots of different ways of doing this.
But here's the key thing that you need to know about cross-site request forgeries.
Who's the target of attack?
Ultimately, who is the baddie going after here?
Is it our user here or is it the web server?
And ultimately, in cross-site request forgeries,
the target of attack is the server.
So here's a quick summary.
In a module before we talked about cross-site scripting,
here's a quick summary of the diff key differences between cross-site scripting
and cross-site request forgeries.
So cross-site scripting, the major thing you need to remember here,
the target of attack in cross-site scripting is the user's browser, the client's browser.
And in cross-site request forgeries,
the target of attack is not the user, but the server.
That's a very important difference to remember
between these two very common types of attacks.